let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud proud
and do not
give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony [ __ ] him
[Music]
a new week
an old weekend an old tired
worn out weekend where we have
the american fascist
running over to a foreign country to
seek shelter
in a foreign autocracy
that is hungry the hungarian autocrat
orban
invites the american fascist
refuge in his country
i don't know if this is a sign that um
that american fascism
is obviously not welcome here i mean
they got to hold their nazi i mean
excuse me their manga rallies their
trump rallies
and abandon and abandon livestock fields
because no one will have them because
they can't pay their [ __ ] bills so
apparently cpac
had to pack up and move to a foreign
country
and i don't i don't think they're
actually exporting american fascism i
think what they're trying to do
is import hungarian style fascism they
love this stuff ah they [ __ ] love it
they [ __ ] love it so much so that the
cheeto dust mobster grandpa poopy pants
himself appears
now most people did not see this until
it was actually posted on a real social
media
uh app
on twitter no no one saw it on true
social
it's all [ __ ] bot accounts over there
they're all [ __ ] fake either that or
they're just trump sycophants either way
trust me i know i opened up a [ __ ]
account on true social i'm on two social
and the minute i posted a video like it
didn't even go it didn't even have a
chance
for the algorithm to pick it up they
censored it that's right true sensor
true social censored my freedom of
speech
so grandpa poopypants
posted on tooth central which he calls
it
that he wants civil war that's what it
appears
and of course this is not surprising
that a dictator wannabe
like the cheeto dust mobster would post
a re-post or whatever the [ __ ] it's
called over there re-shit i guess you
re-shit it over there i don't know you
[ __ ] out stuff on true social you
re-shit it [ __ ] i don't know
i don't know i haven't quite figured out
the platform yet it's a complete copy of
or it's a it's like it's like
if you went down to the half-ass dollar
store right
and you and they ordered a wish.com
twitter
and it came in a really broken [ __ ]
package that's that's what that's what
two central is
but on truth social
the former dictator wannabe
he
re re-shit
indicates that there may be a civil war
which is not surprising again this is
not surprising
that that [ __ ] fascist
that [ __ ] whiny ass little snow white
down at mar-a-lago
would call for civil war that's what he
was calling for
in december of 2020 after he lost the
election got his [ __ ] ass stopped by
joe biden
the american people said no [ __ ] you
don't get to be our fascist dictator no
[ __ ]
go back to mar-a-lago
you [ __ ] snowflake
and he just wouldn't he wouldn't just
do what most decent human beings do
because he is not
that a decent human being
most reasonable people retire from the
presidency with dignity nope not a
[ __ ] ounce of dignity or decency in
that [ __ ]
he continues the scourge
of how he won the election the big lie
you remember
he called on all the proud boys and the
oath keepers which they're in the news
and they will continue to be in the news
for a long period of time here
especially over the summer
but he called on the prowl boys and the
oath keepers to come save him
the moglodites the trump humpers
the maga fascist
dark manga he called on them to come to
washington dc to save his ass
and boy did they try
no did they try on january 6
to make sure
that mike pence did not certify our vote
which is all ceremonial in the first
place we know this and i think frankly
we're going to hear a lot more about
this coming up in the month of june
as these select committees become public
and this testimony becomes public
we are going to get to see the story of
what actually happened on january 6 but
we know a lot
we know a lot
they tried a civil war they tried a
cheeto dust kangaroo coup
we have we have people
in this country who are sitting in
detention as we speak
for a conspiracy to commit sedition
against the united states of america
people who are not too far steps away
from the cheeto dust mobster himself
and we have more and more and more
people we had confirmed this weekend
that the oath keepers more members of
the oath keepers are cooperating with
the federal prosecution
of the seditious conspiracy
where stuart rhodes the founder of the
oath keepers
was in charge of a qrf a stash of
weapons where his lieutenants
joshua james and brian ulrich
were in command
of that qrf and joshua james protecting
roger stone and brian ulrich admitting
in open court when he took his plea deal
that yes he was trying to make sure that
joe biden would not become president
that there was not a peaceful transfer
of power is the words used in open court
there is a civil war going on now
whether you want to believe it or not
there is a coup
attempt still in motion
it's still going they're trying to take
over
the secretary's estate
because frankly the coup didn't work
last time
more like a black practice want run if
you want to call it that
testing it out testing out the waters
find out where the rough patches are
that way you can avoid those rough
patches the next time well guess what
every time is the next time now with
these [ __ ] fascists every single
[ __ ] time is the next time
tomorrow we have the primaries down in
texas we have more primaries around the
country tomorrow
it is time right now is the time to show
these fascists who we are and how we're
not going to put up with their [ __ ]
their hungarian style [ __ ] not gonna
do it go to the ballot you vote vote
vote vote your friends your family your
community members your church members it
is so important
for them to know that we are
pro-democracy here we are not for
autocracy
and there's only one pro-democracy party
in this country right now
unfortunately i wish there was more but
there's not there's only one party that
is interested
and protecting your liberty and
protecting your rights only one
jesus christ they're outsourcing
their fascism their style of fascism to
try to take your [ __ ] liberty
the civil war is ongoing
it will continue folks
and it's gonna continue past trump
the only reason why he's calling for
civil war now or it seems to be that
he's calling for civil war
is because he's [ __ ] terrified he's
painted himself into a corner just like
he did
in 2020 when he [ __ ] lost
he seen the walls closing in he wasn't
going to have the protections of the
presidency anymore
he couldn't fend off
investigations and prosecutions and
indictments couldn't do it any longer
hell his way of life to launder money
may be in jeopardy
so what did he do
he committed civil war on our country
he attempted a cheeto dust kangaroo coup
on january 6
their plan was not to transfer power
peacefully
jesus christ they had a gallows out
front
to hang his vice president if his vice
president do didn't do what the [ __ ] he
said
and they chanted hang mike pence hang
mike pence hang mike pence you don't
think you don't think that's called for
civil war you don't think these [ __ ]
these trumped-up white militiamen
that were in flak jackets and they were
they were ready to go to battle
at the capitol
for what they seen is their their orange
mussolini jesus you don't think
you don't think that is an image of
civil war
you don't think
you don't see it as un-american
you don't see it as unpatriotic
that they wanted to rip up the
constitution and wipe their asses with
it
and declare donald trump the king
because they just can't handle losing
[ __ ] bunch of snowflake [ __ ] is
what they are
scared
terrified
and we could have him on the run folks
we already know that there's eight
million more of us than there are of
them already we know that bare minimum
bare minimum we know there's eight
million more of us
than there are of them
and if you don't think after that after
that vote in 2020 that more of those
people
are on the side of pro-democracy well i
think you're fooling yourself
but don't get complacent this is not the
time
to stand back and want fascism take
control
nor the congress nor the senate
nor the governorships the secretary of
state's the attorney generals jesus
christ all the way down to dog catcher
if they have a whiff just a [ __ ]
stench
of trump
vote them out
it's time right now
today is the time
to beat back fascism
what i want to know
from hungary
we had
we saw
we watched and i'm gonna show you video
today
of their favorite their favorite
dark maga voices
they're leaders of their messaging and
their party
that they took
to hang the hungry
to bow down to the hungarian autocrat
so that they could import
hungarian style fascism here in america
because that's what they want to do
folks that's where the coup is at the
coup is inside our democracy they're
going to use our system they're going to
use our democracy
to try to take it over and topple it
that's our whole goal
that's been their goal for a long
[ __ ] time
a long time
so to act like
that there isn't a cold civil war here
where you're just fooling yourself
you're just absolutely fooling yourself
and until you until you realize
that the coup attempt is still an action
they're not gonna stop they're not going
to quit
they went all the way to hungary
to say the [ __ ] that they can't say here
got it
i'm going to show you
they shipped over the magust of the dark
magist
over to hungary to say the [ __ ] in front
of a microphone that five people watched
literally they're in a little bitty
[ __ ] room it's like a hotel little
conference room
to say the [ __ ] in front of a microphone
that they can't say here
what do i mean by that well here's what
i mean by that
they can't say that [ __ ] here no one
would know no one would have them here
that's why they got to hold their nazi
rallies
and a lifestyle and an abandoned
livestock field they can't they can't go
to [ __ ] stadiums anymore he owes too
much [ __ ] money he's a [ __ ]
deadbeat
but don't underestimate fascist and
don't underestimate fascism
it's time to take them seriously
and this election is the most important
one right now this year forget about
2024 who gives a [ __ ]
as soon as this one's over then we can
turn our attention to 2024 because it
will be the most important election and
the one after that and the one after
that folks they are not going to stop
and you can doubt me
doubt me do it
they're going to ban contraception
they're going to ban condoms they're
going to ban your right
to go into a state once the cheeto dust
confederacy is solidified
they will do it
you watch
you can stand back and say i'm crazy but
in oklahoma as soon as a piece of [ __ ]
hits an egg inside of a woman
as soon as the man ejaculates it is a
human [ __ ] being as far as they're
concerned and the only reason why they
bel they think they are say they believe
that
which is [ __ ] absolutely bonkers and
ridiculous
but the only reason why they say that is
to control
you
they don't believe that [ __ ] [ __ ] no
how could they actually believe that
garbage
the only reason why they say they
believe that [ __ ] is to control
you
and hide behind their christian beliefs
and their bible
their cristo fascism
we see it over the weekend with this nut
bag
down in georgia running for governor
i'll show you a clip i got clips of this
[ __ ] i got all the proof you need
we're gonna show it here today on the
tony michaels podcast just like we do
every single weekday monday through
friday noon eastern 11 central nine
pacific youtube twitter twitch
and simulcasting from the midas touch
facebook page you do not
want to miss a thing
two hours
every single weekday so subscribe to the
youtube channel
where we where we post exclusive videos
you've seen the madison cawthron dark
manga video oh baby i can't play it
anymore that youtube keeps knocking me
on the music
what happens is
disney who owns the rights to the star
wars music
they give us a copyright strike or
whatever it is so i have to silence the
music in the video so then you don't get
to hear it but we posted it separately
so that way you can go watch it
so subscribe to the youtube channel also
do not forget you can watch it on
twitter so go to at tony michael's pod
follow us there
and here's what happens to all the new
listeners out there because we do have
dozens and dozens of new listeners every
single day
which is reassuring that you guys
are hearing this message
but every single day we have dozens and
dozens of new listeners so i want to
tell the new listeners what happens we
go live every single weekday monday
through friday noon eastern 11 central
nine pacific on youtube twitter twitch
and simulcast to the minus touch
facebook page
but after we're live
we we take the audio version
we do a couple things to it you know
make it sound
maybe a little better
run it through a machine
as it were
and we post that on all the directories
apple spotify google all your favorite
directories it is out there
for you to listen to every single
weekday for two hours monday through
friday
so be watching on your directories
subscribe on your favorite directories
whether it's apple spotify or google
give us a good rating over there on
those directories that always helps out
to get our voice out and if you're on
facebook give us a like and also at the
top of the facebook post there is our
youtube channel don't forget to
subscribe there you don't want to miss
the super chat over here on youtube
you got uh
so many new folks in the chat
in the last few months
welcome welcome to all the new listeners
and welcome to you this morning
you guys seem like you had a great
weekend christina's here kelly's here
debbie from salt lake here ann is here
well let's see who else do we have
kathy's here michael forest linda
uh virginia matt gale from facebook is
here debbie justin from facebook margie
from facebook greg nicky trina from
facebook deanna uh let's see who else do
we have we have vinnie
we have mj good morning mj minus robin's
here nancy is here
uh we have kinky streets is here i like
that name um who else do we just have so
many minus margie here
holy moly holy moly we have so many new
listeners welcome welcome welcome to the
tony michaels podcast you know we do not
uh
we
we don't we don't pare down our words
here we don't censor our words much here
as if you haven't noticed already we're
21 minutes in the hour you know gabe
sanchez joins me usually at the bottom
of the hour our co-host and executive
producer gabe sanchez we're gonna go
through the tweety tweets and trendy
trends today that is another thing that
we do here on the tony michaels podcast
for all you new listeners out there
every single weekday we go through the
tweety tweets and trendy turns we also
try to bring you great guest interviews
we have the the greats from legal af
karen agnipolo
michael popock we have the great
political strategist rachel bittikoffer
and so many others so don't forget to go
subscribe to the youtube channel where
you're going to see all that great
content even if you miss
some of these episodes we try to pull
out the best of the best and we actually
post the best of the best every single
saturday and you guys boy you guys have
been watching that as well thank you
very much to all the listeners out there
for the best of the week and then if
you're not aware on friday in the second
hour we do bonehead of the week
bone end of the week we put out a poll
on twitter and youtube more reason to go
subscribe and follow us on twitter
for you to vote for bonehead of the week
and then on friday me and gabe sanchez
break down
who you vote for your vote on the
breakdown of bonehead of the week and we
post it on sundays in and of itself on
the youtube channel
and also on the directory speaking of my
co-host my great co-host gabe sanchez
gabe how are you this morning how was
your weekend
not bad not bad not bad that's good
that's good i i was i i stayed off
twitter as much as i possibly could but
i did try to pay attention to some of
the uh the cpac stuff the uh the
authoritarian civil war type stuff that
was going on over in in hungary it seems
like
i'm not sure i i was asking the audience
i'm not sure if it's um
if they're exporting our type fascism or
they're importing hungarian typefaces
i'm not really sure it's a little bit of
both they're not each other
so it's kind of like a it's kind of like
a dating kind of thing yeah pretty much
i feel like you know you got to go at
least part you know it's like in that
movie uh in hitch he's like i go 90 you
go 10 right okay so i think america is
really going 90 because they're making
the effort to go overseas to hungary
right and then and then hungary's like
yeah we'll we'll hit you at the other
ten
i want to show you some video from this
because i think a lot of people are
discounting this and not a lot of people
i mean not even like
cpac
fans
watch this stuff there was dozens maybe
tens of people in this room okay i i
don't i don't know if i'd say like more
more people or less people than like at
a at an oz kind of rally oh well
you know it's hard it's hard to say how
many is actual media in the room um that
is trying to cover this thing but they
must have got bored too because not a
lot of people even even covered this
i'll actually show you on the cpac 2022
their little their twitter page how
[ __ ] pathetic it actually was we
actually get more views here on the tony
michael's podcast than cpac got from
hungary on their account that's i think
that's something we should write in our
bio i actually think that might might be
something i mean it's not much of
bragging rights because they it sucks to
suck and they suck right yeah but you
know there is that there is that now mj
thank you for the super chat we also
support the pod with super chat she says
thank you very much she must be talking
to some new folks in the youth but gabe
we've got so many new listeners i know
johnny michael yeah yes this is great
yeah i know we've really we've really
the audience is growing every single day
and we're happy to have them here
whether they're on facebook or twitch
or youtube
we love or twitter twitter's are always
our favorite course we yeah we we kind
of live we kind of live
yelling and screaming but it is it's an
anger outlet over on yeah right yeah
twitter i mean you know it's you know
what it is twitter is mainly for getting
mad at things yeah well i mean that's
the whole purpose i thought right no am
i wrong yeah i mean that i would say
it's a combination of like yelling
and then also sharing like
cat dog
videos you know so like you yell and
then you're like oh like a little bit of
a cleanse like you you took the pressure
like you took the the heat off the
kettle a little bit like
and you like ease it off and you're like
this is like a soda stream type thing
you're you're starting to
know but i have my uh my carbonated
water right here audience if you're not
aware um gabe is not only a streamer but
he's a soda streamer yeah dude i'm
double streaming right now dude double
double street double double dipping man
oh my god
but um
yeah i've totally forgot thank you i
totally forgot what i was talking about
yeah well you were talking about twitter
and the reason why i brought it up is
because a lot of things are are you know
there's a lot of things to be mad about
on twitter this morning um you know we
have ty taiwan is uh turning and davos
is trending june teeth is trending
because it seems like a jar of peanut
butter um with the june team thing i
don't know if you've seen this picture
of the weekend i didn't catch a lot of
it i just caught a glimpse of it no
because i was trying to stay off social
media but we also have the republican
party hates border patrol apparently
they do not like it when border patrol
seizes drugs when they're coming up i
think the main problem is that
republicans
don't
know the definition or the meaning
behind seized
you know you know it is it is tough when
you throw out and burn all your
dictionaries it is no no totally i mean
like when you disregard you say i'm not
gonna learn what it is and then all of a
sudden you're like
they they seized so many pounds of this
drug and you're like
so they so they did their job right
right the job is to seize
if they stopped this many pounds
sounds like they did a good job right
right right but according to them
i can't tell if
there should be more of the drugs or no
drugs at all i i can't tell right well
this is this is you know typical
republican double talk right they're
like the same thing with the baby form
like you haven't seen one republican
yelling and screaming about how hundreds
of thousands of pounds of baby formula
has been delivered just in the last few
days to this country like in a moment's
notice within a couple days of this
becoming apparent that in certain
regions of this country we're going to
be short of baby formula that the biden
administration made sure that that
hundreds of thousands of pounds came
from europe landed here and it's going
to be distributed and gave
going to be distributed in red states as
long as well as blue states because it's
all america right babies live
babies live not just in blue states but
also in red states so our president our
president of the united states is going
to make sure that all those babies
receive some sort of uh that sounds like
socialism
sounds
you know you know what's you know what's
funny is
what if there was a baby formula
shortage
under the former guy
what would happen what could possibly
have been the solution
that the former guy you know what the
other uh crazy thing about this baby
formula uh story
is
when they were renegotiating nafta
that's the agreement between
canada mexico and the united states as
far as trade across those borders
trump really fought hard to make sure
that the american people did not buy
canadian dairy right they fought really
hard well he was very ant he said nafta
was a terrible deal we should have never
done it blah blah blah
and then shed all over it
and then obviously his
you know his great deal that he came to
to come to obviously uh
really [ __ ] us over
uh when the going got tough you know
well
here's the thing is he hated canadian
dairy which a lot of people didn't
understand
a lot of dairy comes from canada which
if you think about baby formula and what
it is
and how it works and how it's
manufactured
we used a lot of canadian dairy
to manufacture that formula so he in
essence with his agreement
stopped up part of the supply chain
for baby formula that had to be
recreated here in this country through
our dairy which we only have so much
dairy to produce right and our dairy in
this country the way it's priced and the
way they come up with prices which is
kind of ridiculous is the reason why
dairy farmers really get the the light
into the stick the other thing is we
subsidize commercial farmers and not
family farmers because we just don't
have family farmers anymore so there's a
lot of they can't afford to be family
that's right that's right so they don't
they they just stop being family farmers
they close or move their family so
you're telling me you're telling me you
just can't get infinite milk out there
no no it just you just don't [ __ ] out it
doesn't just grow off trees no no
there's no milk tree i mean there might
be a milk tree there is soy which you
can but you know that they definitely do
not right they definitely do not want
soy milk because that turns people into
liberals
and you can't have that you can't have
that all right i want to point out
midas margie and she says welcome to the
[ __ ] fan new listeners happy to have
you here thank you thank you
yeah new profile pic thank you uh i
guess
um
back to this this formula thing and the
the seizing at the drug border like this
that seizing drugs at the border these
things seem to have the same double talk
oh yeah 100 is the problem here i mean
i last week i called it on monday uh not
regarding the the baby formula but i
said um
i was like i was like i would guess by
friday maybe even thursday
that there won't ever be talk
of the maga king mass shooter he kind of
which in in many ways i think it's like
a you know it's a double-edged sword
right it's good that we're not talking
about him because i don't want his name
right becoming something which we have
never said his name right we have never
yeah we have never said his name i think
we've had to play a clip that had his
name in it but never said i could tell
you right now i do not know his name and
i've done that on purpose right but
during the show i was like i would guess
maybe thursday friday this whole like
thoughts and prayers thing dies down
doesn't even is is not even mentioned
anymore you know also something to be
said on the democratic side as well
which is unfortunate because it is a big
issue
but then you know we've got two
opportunities where republicans can turn
around and say hey
we messed up this whole gun thing though
we will never take a uh
you know like we'll never take
responsibility for we've got a baby
shortage on form baby formula baby
shortage yeah baby shortage well
right now we've got a baby shortage but
if republicans get what they want
they're going to force yeah they're
going to force the manufacturing there
will be a surplus of babies right right
but um you had two opportunities for i
guess a few opportunities right there
was the uh domestic terrorism
that republicans weren't for you had the
baby formula shortage uh bill with 28
million that they were not for right and
then um
you also had the uh gas gouging at gas
stations by oil they were going to they
were going to go after corporate oil
companies yeah they were like we want to
bring you know we want to bring the
price down we want to bring the supply
up all these things that are giving the
opportunity for them to say hey we came
to the table we're part of the
conversation and now coming into the
primaries and also the general like the
midterms we can now say that we did
something to help our constituents and
every time when they step up to the
plate they go the republicans vote for
any of that stuff did they vote for any
other i mean well some i mean
there was uh
all
all republicans voted no on the
um was it the gash the gas gouging one
every single one of them yeah yeah and
then it was i forget the number four for
vodafone baby formula right right and
then for the domestic terrorism i forget
what the number was but i mean you could
look at each time and it's like an
overwhelming amount right it's like most
if not all
like that's just a statement it's like
most if not all republicans
are anti-american right that's just well
it is that that is you know i i'm glad
you brought up the
the manga king mass shooter in buffalo
because there is there is one fascist
still talking about uh the manga king
mass shooter in buffalo and she is
saying that it is racist to call him a
racist apparently or something i'm going
to show you this yeah
yeah well it may have to do well i i
didn't i was not aware of this video i
watched this video i was like wow this
video needs to get out there because
there's only a couple i know a couple
tens of tens of tens of views um but it
it she appears to be in a car
and it appears that she's going to i
don't know like an america first nazi
type rally um you know she's really
she's probably got her three or
four-toed shoes on um so might give you
a hint of who that is so i'll i'll play
that video for you when we go through
the tweets but the other thing i want to
mention about what's what's trending is
don jr has a couple um
it seems like
some of them might be even felonies here
but don jr uh likes to go hunting you
know because he's a tough guy he likes
his guns yeah you remember the eric
greitens video where they were like oh
liberals are scared of guns people yeah
he's like look out liberals were coming
for you right and he's such a tough guy
well and he was shooting at a target
that was standing still well apparently
he does the same thing when he hunts
animals because he's such a [ __ ] he
can't even he can't even go hunt the
animal and track it down he has to have
someone tie it to a tree or draw it in
with a donut or something well that's
the same i mean here's the thing it's
the same for him it's staying for eric
trump it's the same for the ceo of jimmy
john's like all of these people
will be like yeah i got this big game
i'm a big game hunter i'm a man i'm
gonna
my balls while i'm shooting the elephant
but at the end of the day you find out
that they actually send someone out to
go basically
tie it down
or shoot it to injury where it slowed
down to a point where you could actually
track it you know they're basically like
listen this guy this guy who's a tracker
says hey i went out early this morning i
tracked this thing you know for the last
three hours i got him he is you know
whatever this animal is it is it is
slowly tugging along and then let's
let's go out and we'll get you that kill
but you know it didn't
it seems like a
the hunting scandal about the bear and i
think it's in utah i believe is where
they're talking about this where he
lured him in with a donut or some [ __ ] i
don't know i know they lured him in to
with food so that don jr could execute
this this um
this animal you know he didn't actually
go hunted which you know
you know if you're actually going to get
a tag and you're going to get a license
and you're going to go hunt an animal
fine whatever whatever you want to do if
it's legal it's legal
if that's how you want to do it i
believe that's um that that is your
right in this country other countries to
do that as long as it's legal but the
thing the story that really got me in
the hunting story is this mongolia story
did you hear about this he went and he
actually shot a rare some kind of rare
sheep
yeah and he actually had to get a permit
um after he shot it he met with the
president of mongolia um we paid we paid
thousands and thousands and by we i mean
the american people paid thousands of
dollars for this [ __ ] bonehead to go
over
to mongolia to shoot this this this rare
animal um and that he received a permit
for you know after he killed the animal
and we met with diplomats um i'm not
sure uh citizens for ethics uh has the
story maybe we'll find it in the um
tweety tweets when we get to it but one
other story speaking of mountain goats
um have you seen this story about carol
ann conway how trump wanted to have sex
with her and something about her book i
saw i saw a blurb i am not surprised
whatsoever that uh wait wait that he
would he would proposition her or that
she would say no or that what what are
you not surprised because there's a lot
of dichotomy here with i am not
surprised that he would proposition her
right i'm surprised well i'm curious to
know exactly how he went about it did he
just like
flip it out and pull an elon you know
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa slow
your horse down there gabe slow your
horses hey
hey
hey
don't get all horsey on me
so you see you so you think you think he
may have done the whole uh dickie do
where he gets it out
and um i mean showed how
you know i'm not saying you're out then
maybe he like you know he opened the old
hatch act i don't know
but what what i am going to kill and
conway in the hatchet right exactly i i
wouldn't be surprised if
he just
did it
and then you think he grabbed her he
think he grabbed her by the conway you
think i'm
uh it's quite possible i have no idea
these are also images i have never
wanted to put in my brain well that's
why i'm saying i'm here in the morning 9
38 on
the west coast and you're making me
imagine killian conway and donald trump
doing some sort of nefarious sexual act
so
i bring i bring the hard-hitting news
yeah i know and you really messed me up
for the rest of the day uh do you think
she's lying i think she's lying about
this you know i don't know honestly but
i
i wouldn't be surprised if she was lying
right only because you have to imagine
everyone who has released information
about trump and the administration
after they've left right you gotta one
up
each other person you gotta be like this
guy said he was gonna overthrow the
election right this guy you know he said
he wanted to uh he wanted to shoot
missiles into mexico and he wanted to do
this you want to do that like each time
like you know
much like
kind of satire and parody like we have
to heighten reality or the jokes that
are in because we the base reality is
already so heightened and ridiculous and
i think that could be true here too as
well as like the situation is that these
other stories are so crazy right if she
releases a story you know whether she
knew about these things going out
beforehand she might have also been like
oh man i don't know how i'm gonna like
deal with this right like how am i gonna
how am i gonna sell that juicy gossip
right that everyone wants to buy into
juicy i know i'm sorry i'm using the
wrong words here you're really
um
so
i wouldn't be surprised if she did make
this up only as a means of
as as a as a means of of
um trying to improve the sales right and
and uh outdo the ridiculous stories that
have come out right so you're saying
you're saying this book she's writing
she may be putting this in i think she
could be exaggerating possibly because
no one's buying these books apparently
no one's buying right i mean here's the
thing
at this point in our life
anything's possible and i say that like
before i used to say like anything is
possible with like the glimmer of hope
and aspiration that it was going to be
good and just like just like you say
anybody could be president you're like
yeah well and now it's gone from like
anything's possible to
anything's possible you know like that's
really the transition we've made like
the same phrase has a complete 180
meaning and i think that could be true
here is that um she marry she she very
well may have had some type of
experience or exchange
but maybe not to the extent that she's
talking about and i will never know
because i will never read it so if
someone else wants to read it and i'll
just read the cliff notes and get the
gist
whoa whoa whoa he's harzi on the
language sorry i said i said gist
i'm saying jesus no no no no no no i'm
not trying to okay i'm just
double checking here i don't want the
audience to do it i know i'm sorry i
apologize
well i'm going to get that taken out
from the record yeah we'll uh we'll
we'll maybe edit that out yeah there's
another another person in the
administration that is in the news dr
burks uh you remember dr burks is the
one that donald trump looked to when he
was trying to figure out if you could
inject bleach into your body to kill it
she was like um maybe
yeah but he is actually he is actually
uh he truth about her or [ __ ] about
whatever it is that you are truly you
true
it depends on the day
you could be like oh i'm just tooth and
away and then some days you're like i'm
just truth in a way right you know that
way yeah that's what they do over there
they truth a lot yeah a lot dude just
you know massive dumb truth
and you know okay you know
i guess he i guess he troot
about what's funny about this is like oh
his website's so great that they have to
screenshot for anyone to see it they got
to screenshot it and then put it over
right put it on a social media site
where there are actually people posting
and looking at things yeah and and
engaging in content they actually have
to lift it and and post it there but
apparently he said she didn't wear the
dresses or scarves or some [ __ ] or i
don't know what the hell he's saying
about her like yes i'm telling you i'll
show it to you i'll show it to you when
we go we go surf the the tweety trains
and trendy trends but yeah he's he's
knocking on her too so he's trying to
have sex with kellyanne conway he was
really upset that dr burks just didn't
wear the dresses and the scarves that he
wanted i don't know what's with this guy
but i'll tell you it really reminds me
of some some folks the evangelicals out
there but did you hear about
evangelicals in this southern baptist
convention did you hear about this story
yeah yeah which also is not surprising
well i mean is it really surprising that
the southern baptist convention would
actually
uh try to uh tamp down stories of sexual
predators when they supported donald
trump i mean yeah yeah come on
come on this is not surprising [ __ ]
that's not surprising yeah you know this
get the remember that [ __ ] whenever they
get all riled up about something it's
typically gonna be a confession about
something right well projection is there
is the key here yeah and projection is
the key we're gonna see a lot of that in
the cpac
videos that i'm gonna show you here but
one more thing i want to mention before
we get to the tweety reach and trendy
trends if we don't make it when we're
when we're surfing here is uh i think
it's boris
bondarev i think it's how you say his
name he is a russian diplomat um and i
believe he's in geneva
um he has he has resigned this morning
in protest um it looks like a little bit
of uh putin's
uh apparatus his lying machine is
starting to
uh appear cracks are starting to appear
i think the end is coming near
for vladimir putin there's been a lot of
talk around uh what his health is like
and those sort of things um
he definitely i mean how many days are
we into his invasion of the ukraine when
it was only supposed to take a couple
hours
we're really far into this let's see
let's see
and uh apparently also in the news in
russia is they're actually trying to get
people over 40 to join the military um
which
what is next is
young children to be able to join the
military that's how desperate they are
in this fight we are now
80 days oh sorry we are now 88 days into
the invasion of ukraine by vladimir
putin right right which that that is
part of the news from taiwan is uh joe
biden actually is tough on china and
said look we have a one china policy but
if china dare act like putin
and and jiji ping do what putin did to
ukraine to taiwan we will we will stand
with taiwan because we will not stand
for you taking sovereign countries it's
just not something that we do in this
world we should not put up with
sovereign democracies being
bullied by autocracies it's just not
something that we should put up with i i
don't believe which i think is it which
brings up an interesting question if
like let's say that happens and we say
okay hey we're going to come in and
defend
you know does putin
say hey
i'm going to send people over
you know
to hell does he break his already broken
army is that right right exactly so now
now the the army that is already failing
right day after day after day in ukraine
right it was supposed to be like 12
hours ended up being now over you know
it's 88 days and will continue
you know if china invades taiwan and we
say uh not cool we're not doing that
other people come in you know there's
obviously the question of like world war
three but does you do does russia now
look at the situation and say oh we're
going to help china because they are
doing the same thing that we're trying
to accomplish on our end in hopes that
china will then do that now again
they're they're splitting their their
military i don't know if they will or if
they'll just send out like a message and
say we support you you know it's it is
an interesting question of like how far
will russia take it because obviously
their relationship is
you know
is one that's kind of
well i i think you bring up a good point
is i think that's why joe biden's taking
the stand as he's like look there's only
so much autocracy in this world and
western democracy is going to defend
democracy at all costs like that's the
whole [ __ ] point like that's the
point of nato that's that's why we see
even switzerland it's like yeah we're
gonna we're gonna do the whole nato
thing we're not gonna we're gonna
just gonna put in our application here
right so i mean i mean uh we are we are
seeing uh the world pay attention to
defend democracy and we're going to see
more lies about world democracy and
western democracy when we watch these
cpac clips
so stay tuned right after this break
we're going to surf the tweety tweets
and the trendy trends don't go anywhere
we will be right back right after this
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow patriots
what would you do if there is a trump
supporter right in front of you crying
in pain because they have to live under
communist tyranny
we know what you would do you'd reach
out and give that true american a hand
now here's your chance for only 50
dollars a day you can help us help those
true americans recover from biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those trump supporters and this is that
moment
send your donation via venmo to the real
president donald j trump
it's only fifty dollars a day recurring
and it means you'll get these trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime
please donate now because those trump
supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
[ __ ] em
[ __ ] up welcome
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for sticking around through the
break
[Music]
get us a drink a drink of water
gabe's over there streaming streaming
the sodas
streaming the sodas we're going to serve
the tweety tweets and training trends
but i have a few announcements that i
want to make here before we get to the
tweety tweets and the trendy trends is
we got a new we got a new um a segment
coming uh gabe tell us about tell us
about the new segment that we got coming
for folks
so you got something up your sleeve as
it were yeah yeah yeah no sleeves right
now but there's some maybe it's maybe
it's maybe it's in your your stream
maybe something in your sodastream yeah
so what what is this new segment that
you're gonna so uh yeah i'm gonna do a
new segment where i'm gonna
you know some of the same topics that we
we jump into during the show maybe a
little more in depth um but kind of give
you a background on it
um
but the name of the segment is
what was that
and what wait wait what was that what
what did you say what was that what was
that you know because so many so many
times
every single day something will come out
it could be a video about greg locke it
could be something margery taylor green
said it could be
you know herschel walker being
associated with a
veterans program that's a for-profit and
actually under investigation you know uh
these are all things that you would say
hey you miss yeah you may like but you
might say what was that what was it
so yeah you'll you'll be we'll we'll
we'll be showing them on the on the show
but we'll also be uploading them
separately onto the youtube channel so
if you're not already subscribed make
sure to subscribe
it'll be coming up there tomorrow there
will be one about elon musk oh
even better does it have horse is there
horsies involved uh of course he
rides in on a horse on the segment you
know okay good good uh a wednesday i'm
hoping to have one about herschel walker
since tuesday will be the the primaries
so hopefully whatever the outcome is
that we'll be able to oh so you'll be
able to maybe put one together for yeah
yeah so i'm hoping to get one out for
wednesday and then
um yeah yeah i've got another one
i think in in the back that i'm thinking
about there's an updated thing that
happens
so you're just picking out some of these
topics and you're taking a little
a little deeper dive into what what was
said or what was done like yeah yeah
it's just like uh what was that right
wait a second wait a second i'm sorry
what was that reel it back you're right
so you're taking a deep dive into maybe
a specific part yeah yeah and then we'll
be they won't be like crazy deep you
know it'll just be a few minutes to kind
of cover a topic more than just like a
headline or if you didn't have time to
kind of read
a story or whatever you just saw a tweet
or something it could be anything else
it could be an article a video a tweet
it could be some sort of story that
you're like
what was that
this is great see do you have the intro
to play play play the intro yeah for the
folks here go ahead and play it for him
[Music]
look how that's sexy yeah let's play it
one more time oh okay wait go ahead okay
no no go ahead good good
[Music]
so that is the graphic and the sound to
be listening for for the news yeah so if
you're listening out there on the the
the audios the directories apple spotify
google what was that
that is the thing you're looking for
when you get to the what whoa whoa whoa
wait wait wait wait i'm sorry what was
that what
okay this is this is good we're we're
really chugging along here we got the
bone end of the week we surfed the
tweety tweets and trendy trends and now
gabe is gonna bring you a new segment i
know i don't want to uh give too much
away what he's what he said but and how
he's gonna make it look because it's
gonna look a little different than what
we normally know as a as a gabe sanchez
video or the podcast just gonna be me in
a green suit in front of a green screen
so is it like the one with the it's just
it's just gonna be a floating head
and i'm gonna be commenting
on whatever the topic is right that's
fantastic and then you just see me come
and be like what was that
and that's just it that's it that's all
it is yeah i mean it could honestly be
just like that right right you could
just put a video of elon musk saying
he's a republican before we all know the
story of why he's a republican and then
what was that and then
it happens it happens all right everyone
let's get to the part where we surf the
tweety tweets and trendy trends let's
start the countdown
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so the [ __ ] list welcome welcome welcome
back to the show you have reached
the segment that we call the shitless
roundup we round up all the tweety
tweets and trendy trends and we got some
video to show you today you know that's
one of our favorite things to do is show
you the video
the proof
that it is show me the video oh actually
wait hold on that sounds like show me
the covid i'm sorry
show me the video man
show me the real the show me the real
there we go yeah there you go there you
go so there's a lot of stuff going on i
want to show you this a lot of people
miss this
marcia blackburn said we should be
handing
the chinese run world health organ or
should we we should not be excuse me we
should not be handing the chinese run
world health organization any more
authority i said we should not be
handing crystal fascist marsha blackburn
any more authority like merchant
marcia blackburn get that out of here
marsha blackburn is the type of woman
you'd be like oh this is like a southern
doll like bless your heart like she's a
she she's the person that you know
noon on a weekday already has her glass
of chardonnay ready to go you know full
bottle right glass
are you accusing her of drinking too
much is that what you're hey listen i
don't know how much drinks so i don't
know how much is too much is it the hair
that gives it away is it the [ __ ]
hairdo it might be you know bird's nest
or the fact that she's like
fixated
on a word you know and she's like what
is a woman
you know and can't get over that right
can't just look this [ __ ] up in
addiction yeah it's like and understand
that that is a gender that people
identify as i don't understand like the
interns like hey marcia it's in the
[ __ ] book right here and she's like
ah hold on
what is a female what is a woman you
know right they don't know
they're never gonna get it they're never
gonna get it just like they don't get
this baby formula thing here's a news
report from kyle given nbc news confirms
another baby formula shipment will
arrive in the u.s on wednesday
uh fedex
express that's kind of redundant there
isn't it i guess fedex does have an
express service yeah i guess they've got
tears right right but express is one of
them but it is kind of redundant fedex
has secured a government contract to fly
nestle baby formula
from germany to washington dc so it
appears that a nestle factory in germany
is bringing over formula and it says
from there the formula will be
transported to a nestle facility in
pennsylvania
uh via nbc news so kyle confirming
there's another ship you heard over the
weekend there was like 78 000 pounds
i believe is that how much it was i
believe it was 70. i don't know that's
uh i'm not sure of the
yeah i think it was 78 000 pounds that
landed in indiana from europe um
to be distributed you know that's that's
thank you democrats i just want to say
right right well they're i mean
they're the only ones that will do
anything when it comes to feeding babies
in this country
wow democrats deliver well the
republicans are pro starbucks really
delivering right you the goods right now
that is that is correct but see this is
this is the craziest part is they'll
ignore
they'll ignore this entire thing like
they won't bring up the baby formula
thing now because it'll be thrown in
their face so they'll just ignore it
exactly they're just
the only time the only time that they'll
actually bring it up is if they somehow
had to bring up the border seizing
baby formula right there like the border
patrol seized 87 pounds of baby formula
like then you're like okay wait is that
a are you for the border patrol or
against the border patrol very confusing
i don't know what you guys want right
just pick a lane
and go down that lane i know i know i'm
going to show you some crazy videos
speaking of um
crazy folks
wow okay so this this uh patriot takes
has this video here it says a leader of
a parent group that supports nevada
republican candidates
got kicked out of clark county school
board
meeting after going off topic to imply
teachers have sexual relationships with
students
during trips to disneyland these people
are off their rockers now you can only
see
this lady who has the red hair here is
the one going to be speaking you can
only see her from behind here but i'm
going to show you some a thread of that
patriot takes has
um and show you who these people are who
are showing up at these school board
meetings these disneyland let's go
brandon ron desantis nazis is it rhonda
santos in a wig is that why we like like
he's got like a disney wig on it could
be it could it maybe an aerial rit wig i
don't know i mean i don't know i'm not
like it could be i don't know it could
be let's listen yeah which also
california's where we happen to take our
kids for disneyland with this our school
trip can we get disney
we're finding out it's super creepy and
weird california allows you to
wha what this is literally this is a
school this is an official school board
being this isn't like a meeting where
they're discussing a trip to disneyland
that's not what this is this is a school
board meeting where they're trying to
conduct official business yeah how do
these people always like they always
always inject
disney everywhere like
what are you talking about
it is
any any opportunity that they can have
to bring up
something that is totally unrelated and
then she's like this can we stay on
point like can we talk about this this
is the issue that we're trying
how creepy disney is it's related and
it's like what the [ __ ] are you just
don't watch it turn the [ __ ] off if you
don't like disney what the [ __ ] is wrong
with you people if you want to do
whatever you want to watch it ban it
right then do so right just as an
operated citizen you dumb [ __ ]
let's listen to have sex with kids as
long as there's a ten year or less age
difference what that that's where we're
taking our kids with our our sexually
confused teachers who don't have
children of their it might be like
tennessee but i've been with my husband
for 20 something years all right okay so
while he's noticed she says she's been
with her husband 20 years now that's
important to some of the other stuff the
patriot takes found out about this
person who is who is causing trouble at
a school board meeting but listen to
what else she says here she really
i mean you think she's already talking
crazy you haven't even got to the g you
ain't got to the good stuff yet you'll
never have to discuss my sex life in
public because my three beautiful kids
teach your girls not to let every guy
come to them so they want to break
though miss kingsley this is all of your
children
she literally is just like she's going
down it sounds like she's reading her
facebook timeline doesn't it like she's
like oh abortion my children and
ivermectin and i think what's what's
funny about this she goes you know i
wouldn't have to or i didn't have to
bring up my my sex history or whatever
and it's like you are bringing it up
right now you are the one who is making
this now on record they literally
brought they do that don't they yeah
they literally make everything like stop
making me talk about the sex that i
don't have because of that and it's like
dude nobody asks you right i'm telling
you stop making me bring up the fact
that i'm not having sex and it's like
no one's making you talk about that
i i can't understand
these nut jabs but listen
it gets nuttier than squirrel turds here
it gets get even nuttier
um okay can you exactly absolutely no
don't let everyone ejaculate you control
your own body you don't have abortions
planned parenthood responded to kill
minorities
um we're going to
wait wait did she call her a weirdo
let's back it up listen you don't have
abortions planned parenthood
[Music]
against her if she was like weirdo she's
like listen we're gonna take a break i
mean she really does sound you know what
she actually sounds like like there's a
there's a checklist like a bingo items
right of like it's like cabal
disney pedophiles uh you know like uh uh
minorities ejaculation abortion these
are all like hot button topics of a
bingo card and she's just running
through she's like that's right it's
like does anyone have any of these does
anyone right it's like she printed off
her facebook timeline full of memes and
she's just reading what's on the memes
it's insanity yeah like she's like all
right i'm just throwing in buzzwords
kathy has a super chat here she says
early voting in nevada begins may 28th
pay attention to that in nevada thank
you thank you for pointing that out um
and again i think this is in this is in
um arizona i believe uh but let's let's
just
no it no i think it's in nevada it isn't
that yeah um you are you are coming
out of the order
we are in a board meeting this is out of
order miss kingsley please leave she's
snapping no yep and they know her name
they know our names they're like oh my
god miss kingsley it's another tuesday
right this [ __ ] crazy ass
crazy-ass coop just queueing on coot but
facebook ivermectin weirdo
weirdo uh weirdo that's totally what i'm
gonna say she said i don't care no
you don't get it you don't get to
control hey you can hey you have a box
of pubic hair you have a bug you have a
bug
i told you i told you it gets weirder it
gets weirder she starts to keep pointing
at people and talking about how they got
a box of pubic hair what the actual i
don't know tony what did you make us
watch i i'm telling you look you can't
look away from this stuff these people
are trying these people are trying to
get [ __ ] people elected i'm gonna
show you why
this video is so important and patriot
takes pointing this out because
sometimes patriot takes
they'll post something and i'm like is
this is this relevant or is this just
something he's trying to show us so
we're paying attention to something else
this doesn't seem relevant but when i
show you some of the posts that they
have and who they're supporting it may
it may seem relevant to you have you
collected low love brooks i know about
your book i know about your book of
pubic hair
now it's a book a pubic hair not a box
you know this is the thing about about
uh school board meetings folks is that
you do not have to let these boneheads
take over these school burnings they are
actually official meetings um there is
an order that is happens in official
meetings just like when you go to a
state house to a legislator and you're
being disrupted to their official
proceeding they can remove you right
like you can protest and you have the
right but they can remove you from being
disruptive to their official meeting
like they can't do that yeah yeah if
they want to just like here she should
be escorted out and really honestly
it would be heartbreaking if the door
was opened um with her
i'll just show you some other video or
some other pictures here here's what
patriot takes post uh her name is um the
parent below is stephanie kinsley who
yells at clark county school board
meeting about crt oh look a white nation
okay right well this is her husband okay
i'm here
right dude now now this isn't this isn't
like pulled off some sort of cell phone
or something like that
this guy is posting this [ __ ] on
instagram right and you see his little
his little sign here
you know right here there you go got it
got it yep yeah you got get but this is
snuck it in there at the last second
right here's here's another instagram
post that the guy post i'm not a racist
i just like choppers
swastika right
right hmm it it really would seem
it's just like i'm not racist i just
don't like black people it's kind of the
like yeah yeah yeah
here's his here's his wallet apparently
wow whatever this is i'm not sure what
this is is that a wallet yeah it's like
it's a handmade wallet you know right
he's just like you know he put the
little what is that what is the little
ss lightning bolt what does that mean oh
that's crazy that looks like something
i've seen before maybe uh from a from a
like a group that supported hitler or
something yeah i'm not real sure also on
this it's
gonna be on this motorcycle too those
aren't lightning bolts that doesn't mean
fast fast
that means fascist fascist right
[Music]
oh man
these guys don't give up now it gets
better even still
um here's some more instagram posts oh
okay
yep and here's some more from
yep yeah
oh here's another one here's another
great picture
life and then this these ss lightning
bolts seem to keep appearing in place
wow it's almost like almost like there's
an ideology yeah that's crazy like he
believes in something right right um
do you think do you think he got that
tattoo when he got married to his wife
or he was like you know i'm with you
through you know life and death you know
like ss and she was like i love you
honey now here is here's the husband
we've seen in the picture before and the
the wifey was but look look at the uh
the shirt that this guy has on huh that
seems funny
look at that yeah here's another one uh
here's another great post that they had
tits out for the boys and apparently
this is their boys in a 69 car yeah no
because
because you should not sexualize
children at all yeah yeah tony stop
indoctrinating these kids stop trying to
put sexual thoughts in their minds
definitely you definitely shouldn't put
crude sexual it's just a statue yeah i'm
assuming this is actually like a david
like a replica of davis
oh you know what this would make sense
if he's in vegas might be then he's
taking a photo at another okay here's
the guy as well is this is this
something like harambe thing that i i
have no idea what what what this is um
here we go again now here's why it's
important
these people are running around doing
fundraisers for politicians to get
elected in their state
these what appear to be [ __ ] nazis is
what it appears they're neo-nazis
um and uh here is
here is her account here uh patriot
takes posted this picture
uh and he actually says
update stephanie stands by nazi imagery
posted by her husband's account here's
what she says in this post on twitter it
looks like that's what it appears to be
to those
to the loose liberal which i don't
understand that what does that mean i
don't know maybe maybe there's maybe
she's making the accusation that like
liberals are loose in like sexual and
like prostitutes and [ __ ] and i kind
of think right i don't know i don't know
it seems like you're getting away with
the statues
right i don't know the projection is
real with these [ __ ] but it says to the
loose liberals trolling my husband's
account and tweeting photos
there is not a photo you will find that
i am ashamed of she's not ashamed of any
of those votes yeah that's the best line
there is not right not one there's not
one on his instagram single [ __ ]
photo right you cannot shame me
with my with my fashion i'm ashamed of
right like i said when they got married
she got prop i guarantee she's also got
a tattoo somewhere maybe maybe by her
hips or something or like at her ankle
or maybe the inside of her wrists
that's a little like ss you know and
it's like her name and then his name and
works together bound by love well her
name is stephanie so maybe it's
like double s definitely i don't know i
don't know here's here's the thing
though
is that this person you know i told you
that in the in the little rant she had
her saying her husband of 20 years
is i told you that would be significant
so she's they've been doing if there's
an affair that has happened or something
like that i am ready for it well you
know i'm just saying that they've been
doing this for a long time she also says
in this tweet
you on the other hand will be reminded
of the loving family you will never have
i'm not sure what that means
it seems like a maybe a threat but i you
know i don't know these these snowflakes
are you know
gutless when it comes to threats so
that's really clark county sd what is sd
um i you know school district that might
be that might be so she may be
threatening the school district right
and i don't know what this i don't know
my family my children's habit i don't
know what that is down there i'm not
sure what that is i don't know
i don't know very very strange pagetakes
has this um all posted on their account
and i'm gonna go ahead and retweet this
post here so you guys can find this
thread it's in the thread that i posted
earlier but there you go gabe see these
people are these people are off they're
[ __ ] rockers dude they're [ __ ]
white they're out there i didn't even i
did not expect this uh well i don't know
i mean like every day i'm like oh what's
the [ __ ] [ __ ] gonna be today you know
right right well well i got another
weekend i'm like oh yeah this is great
like i had some time off and then of
course they come back and it's like the
fascists are
civil wars
right speaking speaking of fascist and
crazy crazy wackadoos
this video has did not have very many
views this morning i don't know 20 30
000 yeah and i i thought this really
needs some more coverage so i actually
tweeted with it um
buffalo manga king shooter energy now
marjorie taylor green is not going to
apparently stop talking about how
we keep saying that the maga mass
shooter manga king mass shooter is a
racist when he clearly is
it clearly was his mission to go kill
black people in buffalo new york
um and he was using the rhetoric that
her and cucker carlson steve bannon
donald trump are also boarding elise
stefanik are all supporting but listen
to how she frames up
how people are racist
when they say things about the manga
king mass shooter because he is the real
victim here gabe he is the real victim
i mean not sorry not on the jail on the
bill or this domestic terrorism um new
bill that came out for the department of
justice and jerry nadler was on the
house floor and he was talking about
white supremacy and he was bringing up
the terrible shooting that happened in
new york but totally ignoring the
shooting that happened in california so
here's here's what here's what she
starts with is
is uh
white nat this bill against white
nationalists is a bilge white people is
what she's saying
and truly a white nationalist would
believe that like if you really were
believing and wholeheartedly
your ideology is white nationalism you
would believe that a bill
that gives the department of justice
more authority to really crack down on
white nationalism and domestic terrorism
you would you really
are a white nationalist like that is
your ideology and she clearly is taking
that stance here is that is that white
nationalism she's saying all
not in so many words that white
nationalism is not domestic terrorism
it's not tied to domestic terrorism but
listen to what she says
about race
and who's the racist um that i think
involved an asian man that was a shooter
totally ignoring the guy that drove his
car um black man that drove his car
through a christmas parade killing
people and was a racist himself
completely ignoring ignoring the black
man that did the new york subway
shooting you know these people are all
guilty of these crimes and it's not
about rape it shouldn't be about race um
but they're clearly but it shouldn't be
around about race yeah no but there's
the but this is it's even before she
started this it became one huge what
aboutism
hey guys look i know you're going after
this white kid but that's not really the
problem jerry nadler was on the house
floor and he was talking about this
stuff but he didn't even bring up this
black guy or this asian guy he only
brought this white guy it's an attack on
white people but let me tell you what
about what about this other one what
about this other one what about this
other one like that's what she's playing
here she's playing the the the racist
what about ism to say well it's not it's
not all white people
you know not all white people are bad
she's like they're they're the other
people the black people and asian people
they're all so bad they're also bad
they're racist you know they're killers
but it's only white people that are bad
oh my god this is disgusting what is
what does america come to
right that we can't admit that someone
who said out loud that they were gonna
go kill black people right their mission
was like she's trying to erase away the
fact yeah that the manga king mass
shooter in buffalo was there to kill
black people they don't want people to
know that and the reason why is because
they actually they support that right
they support that like she is doubling
down to defend a person that has is
self-proclaimed to be an anti-semite and
a white supremacist and then she decided
to go hey guys guys hold on you know the
take i'm gonna do today i'm gonna say
how you're all racist for calling him
out for what he said about himself right
trying to try to beat that
right well oh listen to the end here it
gets great hopefully racist as well do
it
it shouldn't be about race um but
they're clearly racist as well so the
white supremacy shouldn't be the main
target we should be more concerned so
she is not she does not want white
supremacy to be the target folks
like literally she's saying it out loud
folks she's saying it she's saying hey
i'm a white supremacist i want to defend
white supremacy
it and if you are against white
supremacy you are a racist that's what
she's saying guys stop talking about the
white supremacy okay
it's not a big deal it's like my white
supremacy
yeah so what he said
it's like yeah okay this like maggot
king mass shooter decided that he was
gonna go out and he said deliberately he
was gonna kill black people it's like
what are we saying he yeah okay sure he
said he was a white supremacist an
anti-semite but it's like guys let's
just stop talking about the white spicy
okay right let's let's make sure let's
make sure to victimize white
supremacists right the [ __ ] out of here
with this [ __ ]
good lord learned about the illegal
invasion at the border the crime
happening
on our streets not about the race
like chicago we should we should go
after criminals that break the law and
not
pursue people based on their skin color
and and how they vote but that's what
that's what the democrats want to do
all the projection game the projection
at the end
is so sweet the democrats are going
after people of color
and so and she wait i'm sorry did i
catch that right she said at the end
that democrats were the ones who were
well yeah because because democrats are
going after white people democrats are
going out their way and that poor that
poor manga king mass shooter in buffalo
we wouldn't be going after him if he was
black like right he went there and
killed people we wouldn't be we wouldn't
be prosecuting we would let him go gabe
get the [ __ ] out of here with this [ __ ]
it's amazing because the the pro-life
crowd will easily go after someone who
is a person of color who has done
something that is illegal but if it's a
white guy
they're like oh my god i'm so glad that
we did not abort that baby
like that's the that that is the logic
and rationale that i hear them say you
know they're like oh my god
thoughts and prayers i'm so glad that we
did not abort that life like oh my god
can you imagine if that life was not
around
he wouldn't have been able to do what he
did right yeah they're what they said
they are totally excited
oh they love it getting their jobs off
right
you know it's speak speaking of people
who are i'm really excited about racism
and taking away people's liberty and
also giving people explosive diarrhea
right
and having diarrhea come out of her
[ __ ] mouth this is as everyone knows
lauren bobert the bobo the clown now
this game this is a video that she
produced here
like this isn't like this then this
isn't like this is not like
someone recorded her saying something
posted on the internet this is [ __ ] that
she's like yeah this is really good we
should post this listen to the words out
here the fascist word sound listen
oh to the duh just listen the bible
tells us to declare a thing and it shall
be established and we declare on this
day
okay first off i want to bring something
up here wait wait wait
sorry say what are you going to say and
then i want to go back well
i was i want to say that her music is
way too loud in the background like you
can't you can't hear what the [ __ ] she's
saying she really needs to figure out
when she's producing these videos how to
adjust the volume from the music and the
yeah yeah maybe maybe she's thinking
this is a dramatic effect she's like
she's like listen there's not a lot of
people at this thing right now there's
like maybe a couple of dozen right
there's
people he's like i learned i learned
from the best trump tight shots
tight shots
music we'll put in some sound effects i
also want to point out
that uh
when you know that video where she made
where she was like walking she's like
this is what i do before i vote and
she's like walking down and goes up the
steps the one that i paid oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah where smash
mouth where's snapchat yeah who also
commented was like oh we don't [ __ ] dad
do not put my music with her
but in that video she actually uses uh
sound effects for her walking
right because she had she used the same
exact uh foley sound that i used
but i just did it better
so you synced it up better yeah i synced
it up but i'm telling you that the sound
that she added is actually an it is a an
exact copy
of the foley sound that i use to
actually add the footsteps
on the video but there is something here
if you go back to the beginning of the
video look at this sign that says it
says purple sash right and it says equal
rights for pre-born women yeah if you're
looking at the if you're looking at the
the thanks
the 420 god for the super stick right
here thank you let me pull the banner
down here so you can see this
um full thing that he's talking about
here
right if you see the mouse here it's
it's pre-born women yeah pre-born
not not not living women right not the
ones who are already well [ __ ] hey
gabe gate
hey [ __ ] the women who are here right
[ __ ] them why would we want to protect
them no not especially the ones
especially the ones that want to have
liberty over their bodies right yes
which is surprising because she had you
have other people like margie taylor
greene who says that men
are the superior gender right in
in this world that we live in then
you've got you know lauren bobert over
here that's advocating for pre-born
women now i don't know if she's the
person that is like pushing this
movement movement i say in quotes or if
it's someone else and she's actually
talking but the fact that you have to
fight for pre-born women but are
unwilling right to fight for just the
women who are already living and
existing listen listen
this needs to be a fascist state game
this needs to be a fascist state and in
a fascist state you can't let adult
grown-ass women have liberty and decide
what they want to do with their bodies
you just can't have that kind of [ __ ]
because that leads to all kinds of
equality and equity you know that you
just can't have that kind of [ __ ] and
well here's the here's the other thing
too is
you don't
you
what i find funny about this is you
can't find out the gender of a baby
until like 20 weeks in
so before 20 weeks
who's whose rights are you fighting for
you have to wait until 20 21 weeks or
whatever maybe 15 at the earliest before
before the guy even gets a boner before
the guy even gets a boner game god has
decided whether that is a pre-born woman
or not right gay right so you just need
to chill out and listen to the bible or
something i i i okay fine i will
let's listen to what the bible
the so-called bible thumper has here to
say the word salad whoosh the bible
tells us to declare a thing and it shall
be established and we declare on this
day that life wins
thank you father god
does it look like she cutting clips from
another audience it very well could be
it almost looks like she did like
they're not actually that's like
someone just like in a crowd on a street
right or she like goes through like yeah
pro life's an american garb like here
this one's wearing an america shirt this
one has a problem let's look at the
spacing here they've got a lot of open
gaps here people moving around well the
crowd might have been small and they had
to kind of cut other clips and make the
crowd look bigger i mean it might be it
might be for her pre-born women in the
crowd there i guess i don't know these
justices
have wisdom
and revelation in the knowledge of you
that they may know the hope of their
calling that they may stand boldly
today we celebrate life
and
[Music]
we celebrate life right as though it is
already literally i i'm telling you man
there is going to be in the next few
months there is going to be talk someone
some one of these nut bags are going to
be in front of a microphone saying that
god knows before the man even gets an
erection god knows yeah that that is
going to be a human being or some crazy
[ __ ] what i really want to happen right
now is i want someone else from the
republican party to fight against this
little movement here to be like what
about men right what about pre-bull men
oh oh america first is probably all over
that i i'm sure nick fuentes would be
very upset that lauren bobert is
protecting pre-born women here yeah that
that it is it is a crucial and essential
that you must protect pre-born men
because pre-born men are way
way better and way way more superior
especially pre-born white men are way
more spear yeah yeah yeah
let's let's this disc does look like
stock footage man
there's i i i'm not believing
because no one's wearing purple sashes
right yeah i don't see no one has the
purple sound she's purple anywhere
and for all we know
she could have
uh
filmed this
and then it could have been what the
[ __ ] oh my god people who raised their
this is i mean this is i mean it was
never really a big thing in the catholic
church i was a part of but like this
type of raise the hands and like oh yeah
i feel it i'm like evangelical
i mean it really yeah you know that type
of [ __ ] freaks me the [ __ ] out because
here's the thing you can easily go from
two hands
down to one hand and it be something
totally different like this one right
here
we need to take this screenshot and gabe
you might want to keep this for your uh
for your collection this one here
uh i don't know i just need to do that
i'm not even going to play the rest of
this well i want to play the end oh my
god
this guy yeah
christian rock or who is cult rock
whatever kid rock wanna be
i don't know what does this shirt say
reverse free speech maybe i don't know
reverse row probably or something
reverse the reverse
something
reverse the
stupidity go back go back go back there
i think there's another shot of him
no
go back oh back back back back back well
that's just his oh that's just his great
hair he does have good hair though yeah
good hair i'm gonna give the guy that
yeah he's got way better hair than [ __ ]
rock way better hair than kid rock i
mean look at look at the curls in that
[ __ ] yeah that's [ __ ] radish but
again you see here it's a low shot you
can't really see beyond a couple rows of
people
right but see there's a woman down here
in purple and then the theme is purple
but i don't see like
any other thing indicating oh here's the
here's the podium over here on the side
okay all right there's the circle right
so there's something on the other side
does that mean that she reused that sign
for something else i i'm not sure
there's that is the podium it looks like
a it looks like a
maybe an m and a v like yeah
they cut it out and re-printed on the
back and made it so on one side it's
supporting american veterans possibly
it's what it looks like
right here right now this podium here is
what gabe's talking about it says av
something yeah it's like a it looks like
the next letter to the a is like a base
b like the first leg of an m and then
the bottom is v
and then the next one looks like it
could be the next one as an e
so i'm sorry times are tough for these
fascists i'm going to show you this in
the cpac video i'm going to go to the
innovation that's crazy right i really
i really want to maybe what they're
upset about i want to show you the
ending because she's really proud of
this video watch this
she's doing it again she's doing it
again look
whoa
that's a hard degree
she's really got the elbow straight and
the fingers out there like this isn't a
half-assed josh holly not no no that's
not a fistful she's really getting
[ __ ]
you know sending out a wave to right
normally if you're gonna do this you
want to have the hand like up like this
right i don't know yeah like right like
really or not even like fully extend
just like hey right like hey you know
you're witnessing or whatever the hell
it's called i don't know but this
boy she's got that [ __ ] arm straight
nose fingers are pointed yeah i'm not
saying there's gonna be a photo of her
later that maybe he has been manipulated
somewhat by me but there might be here
it is well let's let's listen to the end
here
[Music]
she's really proud of it even has her
signature oh look at that dude look this
photo in the back here look she even
yeah she's even got oh man
the projection's strong with these [ __ ]
oh my god oh my god
well
i i i applaud her for trying to do some
kind of production value but lauren i
don't know who your team is you really
need to quiet the music yeah turn up the
volume so you they can hear all the
garbage that you're trying to say
you really need to try that
try that speaking of some more crazy-ass
word salad
and before we go to the cpac videos
because i actually think he made this 4c
pack i think that's what this was made
for i'm not i'm not 100 sure
but you think this is like uh
this is like
the equivalent
of
clint eastwood talking to a chair it
might be this is john well it looks like
santa claus
yeah that really needs a [ __ ] nap and
that's what i tweeted santa claus can
you imagine being santa claus and having
to go around the world in one night
but john voigt here you know he's he's
lost his
he lost his mind a long time ago but
he's been supporting trump this whole
time he he talks about q anon type [ __ ]
he always appears in front of a uh of in
front of a folded well
not so
i mean there's a crease i can see a
crease in the back here yeah there's
several creases this is boom clearly
duct tape this to the wall behind him
yep yep yeah to uh he probably
if i had to guess he probably bought it
on amazon you know probably made in
china you know right probably sent over
the day before right but it's clearly
like this has been folded you can see
one i can see two i can see three
normally you fold the flags you normally
pull the flag but it's not folded like
in a package like this right this is
fold like in
uh into maybe a third
and then fold it over right right now
that's the proper way yeah not the
actual i'm going to fold this into a
triangle be respectful of the flag
for a group that says they love the flag
and they don't want to tarnish the name
they'll do anything to buy the chicken
any clothing they'll buy plates with it
and all this stuff
now let's listen
let's listen to
i'm not going to play the whole thing
because it's just too much to watch but
listen we lost our love
for life our hope our faith
and we shut down
it's it sounds pretty dark gabe it's
getting pretty dark like he's lost all
faith now listen
through the dark we found some light
we made music we cooked
we tried to laugh do you think he's
improvising this or do you think someone
wrote this down for him to say i think
he's reading it surely
do you think he wrote it because this is
just garbage like he's just saying light
to dark dark i think like i think he
wrote it
i think he wrote and i think he's
reading what he wrote
i'm trying to i'm also trying to track
his eyes right now and i think they're
moving
towards a piece of paper
he kind of says the same [ __ ] and he
talks about how trump is the light and
the darkness came and some [ __ ] and the
q anon [ __ ] and the queueing on here and
queueing on there and queueing on
everywhere but listen to the end this is
pretty much all words out but listen to
the end of life
we live was turned upside down but now
i'm here to say that we will rise
for we are here now and we are living
the story of god's glory
a family of love a family of truths
i mean i don't i really can't even put
together what the [ __ ] this is about
like these people
these people just have a super difficult
time
of putting words together i don't really
i don't i just don't
really [ __ ] weird uh okay so we're
going to go to the cpac i really want to
show you this cpac account
and it's what i want to show you because
i want to [ __ ] [ __ ] all over them to
be quite honest with you so is jon
voight the hollywood elite
well i mean game he's not an a-list game
elites are the ones who are part of the
soros cabal
that the one the elites you are not are
part of
you know the normal man's movement the
movement right right right right they're
trying to take down hollywood from the
right side right they're there they're
there to do their job john boyd has been
there for decades and decades
and he sees the light and it's the dark
but he needs to turn the light on so
that god's glory can show him the
darkness that is the light that will
bring him to the light but give him
darkness right i don't i don't know yeah
no i you know what i followed that uh
not at all
right it makes total sense it does
absolutely just like this page here
makes sense if i want to show you that
this is that don jr giving someone the
finger no i'm just kidding but is that
john junior coked out talking with
somebody it is don jr here now if you
notice here
cpac 22 this is the account cpac 20.
cpac's account but they got 2022 here
texas they didn't make a [ __ ] graphic
for the hungarian
for their their their avi their what is
it called here the the [ __ ]
what is this
yeah whatever it is whatever the hell
this is called they didn't make a
graphic for that probably because they
didn't want people to know that it was
there like well he could all say hey
they didn't hungry and they could say no
we did it remotely from a place in texas
when you go down this feed you'll know
that not a lot of people knew it was in
hungary because not a lot of people
tuned in but here you see kimberly
guilfoyle
uh and donald trump talking to matt
schlapp here which we're going to hear
from
in these videos
um just to give you an idea of what kind
of content we're going to be watching
here the largest and most influential
gathering of conservatives in the world
cpac
awake not woke and that is very
important that they're awake
not woke because you don't want to get
confused here i guess yeah
very confusing um so they posted some
stuff this morning here's here's a great
advertisement for one of their their
main messengers candace owens we're
definitely going to want to watch a
video from that you know what's great is
when you have can you go up really quick
just with that
or i will yeah
uh the logo that she has there right you
would assume
that cpac was a hungarian
it is hungarian right you would assume
that when you see that you go oh yeah
yeah cpac hungry like you've got the
flag there
not
cpac that it's like oh we want to you
know we want to have red white and blue
because we want people to know it's
american it's usa like that's who's
really doing it but here it looks like
it's oh cpac is a hungarian run
enterprise it it is i think i think
that's why they had to go to i mean
tucker carlson went there a lot of
conservatives are going there maybe
they're looking for a place to land if
you know
we run fascist out of this country like
we
should make them irrelevant you know
they have to go find relevance somewhere
and that's where they're going to is
hungry
but there's a lot of a lot of um
let me show you here so
this is um let's see
here we go here we go this is from may
21st so this is on saturday
and this is uh jack
what's his name jack prostate what's his
[ __ ] name the the pizzagate guy
you know what i'm talking about
oh yeah pizzagate pizzagate guy so this
this this is pizzagate guy
at hungarian cpac
hungarian fascist cpac now he's the
quote here is this is new communism for
a new age
this is the voices that they shipped
over there
to talk in hungary for american
conservatism quote unquote american
fascism manga
listen to what this [ __ ] [ __ ] box
says again this is the guy who came up
with pizzagate which caused some loony
to go into a pizza parlor and start
shooting at people in washington dc
listen
wokeness globalism open societies
technocratic neoliberalism this is a new
communism for a new age
remember the lady at the [ __ ] at the
[ __ ] school board meeting yeah you
remember that it's almost like they got
the same [ __ ] script
it's almost like he's reading off of
memes listen again wokeness globalism
open societies technocratic
neoliberalism this is a new communism
for a new age what in the [ __ ] is he
talking about
i don't understand after this i i don't
know i mean basically they're like all
right guys we need words and we need
good buzz words right we need all the
best buzz words
and so they're just like
all right uh yeah just throw some like
woke something about woke in there right
technocrats
neoliberalism what does that even i mean
i don't get it like they don't their new
maga king is the king of technocrats
he's supposed to be the inventor of uh
uh
digital virtual payments and electric
cars right i mean that their new manga
god
here is here's bonehead central here um
candace owens they ship the best of the
best over there and really actually i
honestly believe the reason why they
they paid to have these [ __ ] go over
there is because they couldn't have
anyone
i mean there was tens of people watching
this but they could get less people
watching this over here i mean look at
this video 6 500 views
candace owens has millions of followers
man they can't even get they couldn't
even buy more views for this video you
couldn't even buy more views on this one
but but watch this [ __ ] bonehead
listen to what she says about wokeness
and communism
they're really selling the communism
hard seems what do they have in common
right you have the climate alarmism
oh client that oh that sounds communist
you have children that are being told
they can pick their gender you have that
sounds really communist that that people
have you know like thoughts and stuff
women that are after the abolition of
men
who the abolition of of men because
that's that's a really big problem here
in this country yep
what
and it's very easy to say well this is
just incompetence and chaos and we
should fight that but it's more
important to understand that all of
these have one thing in common and
this is going to be really intellectual
here gabe are you ready for your mind to
be blown i don't know i don't know maybe
jesus the answer is that they are an
attack on the family
if you want to understand the left you
have to understand that they are not
incompetent in fact they are quite the
opposite they are we are very smart gabe
hey i like that we are
we are not incompetent we know exactly
what we're doing hey
you know what's funny is here on the
left everyone's like damn right suck
they don't know what the [ __ ] they're
doing they don't have a message right
and then she's like yeah they're really
confident they know what the [ __ ]
they're doing like come on get out of
here
methodical and they are machiavellian
they have sat down and they have thought
about these topics deeply every day two
hours a day i sit down and i talk about
these topics candice you really should
come over here and take a listen if you
think we're intellectuals and you think
you know what we're doing you really
should take a couple hours a day to come
over and watch we sit here
every single weekday monday through
friday and talk about these kind of
things you really should come join us
you [ __ ] bonehead
they are marxists here we go here's the
captain this is what precedes communism
you want to understand what left you
need to understand marxism yeah you need
to understand karl marx you need to
understand why in all of his writings he
was after the abolition of family
when you put family at the forefront of
your mind and you because that's exactly
what marcus marxism says gabe yeah like
that's exactly the family
gotta go
they he says it i mean that's like the
whole book like right it's just one page
and that's what it says yeah no families
just do away with them your problems
will be solved yeah communism yeah like
[ __ ] your family right
that's criticism that's the definition
you re-examine all of these categories
it suddenly becomes crystal clear that
yes they are all an attack on the family
seems what what do they have in common
right you have [ __ ] bonehead so um
candace owen gets 6 500 views now the
reason why i show it is because folks
this is this is the quiet [ __ ] that
they're saying to each other right she's
trying to spread at a bunch of manga
type dummies over in hungary
about what marxism isn't right she's
gaslighting now
if you move on down here because i'm not
going to play too much more of this i
definitely wanted to play those two
parts they're main messengers but the
one thing i want to show is a couple of
the live feeds here
this is really important i think
um in the grand scheme of things here is
a live feed this is day two gabe where
match lap is opening it up um and i want
to show you here
that's this is eight hours eight long
and a half hours long they got
1374 people to tune into this now here's
why this is important this is why it's
super important is because during a live
feed on twitter it is very hard to get
bot accounts to watch that feed and get
the count for viewership did you know
that it's very hard on how the old
periscope and how they pipe it in it's
very hard to get bot accounts to watch
that to get views
1300 [ __ ] views people may twentieth
this was friday
this was fun but i thought uh i thought
the bots there were so many bots there
were so many bots on twitter that could
make these views happen according to
elon right they couldn't this has got 15
retweets
this is day two this is the broadcast
from cpac or in hungary
this is how interesting we had more
people watching our eight hour live
stream of the marjorie taylor green
at one time at a given moment yeah yeah
we had more people and then collectively
this is this is the aggregate this is
the sum that's right thirteen hundred
people watch this and this has been this
has been three days that this has been
up right eight and that's all hours
that's also not this also i guarantee is
not actually 1374 people this is
probably like 600 people if that
re-watching
opening up in a new browser opening up
in a new ip address like i guarantee
let's let's just go look at the um
because i want to break this down a bit
let's see who retweeted this um of
course it's a bunch of you know trump
humping fools no verified accounts not
one verified account retweeted this nope
nothing of course not and that's it
here's the quote tweets let's see okay
there's this there's one verified
account that quote tweeted it
one
that's how exciting i don't even know
who that is i i don't either
neither neither does cpac or match slap
what i'm trying to point out here folks
is that
the [ __ ] fascists in this country
aren't even excited that they went and
did this because the bill the billing
that they got was [ __ ] candace owens
and jack pizzagate yeah that's who they
got to go speak
prostate
jack prostate yeah whatever but yeah it
is one of those things where it's like
it makes me feel
like they're like yeah yeah we we did
this thing right oh that that verified
account that verified account was
actually
was actually against them
oh
the most embarrassing representation of
the usa i've ever seen
and seen a thing or two but wait did
they retweet that
no no no this is a cool tweet on that
broadcast got it got it got it gotta get
it okay so so
uh berg here
is retweeting or quote tweeting this
broadcast so that's the one the one
verified cap they got a liberal
and i'm sure george soros paid for this
quote oh yeah
i'm sure he's super he's not too far
away he's super concerned about all
these viewers that are watching this
stuff folks here's the thing here's what
you have to know about this and this is
why this is so relevant and so important
is guess what they don't like
that the cpac was over in hungary they
don't like it
so do something about it bring it up
every single moment you can it is the
wedge that can be driven between them
right like we're always looking for
wedges we're always looking for ways to
drive wedges between them to break up
their electorate here it is here it is
they're so they are so [ __ ] out of
tune and out of touch that they couldn't
even bring in 14 and really honestly
we're one of the viewers here we're one
of the viewers on this [ __ ] count
right
because i'm playing it for a certain
amount of time even with the volume off
i mean i can tell you
that
i went i just went to their youtube page
okay on the channel
and they have you know they they stream
pretty regularly
two days ago yeah yeah cpac two days ago
three days ago
um but i'm not finding anything of them
oh wait hold on
cpac now i don't know where they
actually are though well here's here's
the here's the the bridge to give you an
idea before
yeah so just to give an idea 130 like
whether or not this happened in
hungary where they were they were
actually doing this 135 as in 135 views
113 113 140
this channel on youtube has 42 and a
half thousand subscribers
it's all bought and paid for
the same right none of the none of this
stuff exceeds 200 views or maybe like
right
well see that's the thing though that's
what i'm trying to tell you is cpac it's
all [ __ ]
the messaging that they're pumping out
is all [ __ ] it's all [ __ ] fake
it's phony and listen they don't buy
this messaging that no one's buying this
hungarian
this hungarian cpac messaging so use it
out there when you guys are messaging
and you're talking about [ __ ]
fascists out there bring up this
hungarian thing to these [ __ ]
fascists draw wedges in between them
that's what they do to us we have to do
it to them
because here's the first day of the
broadcast or of the uh and they got 20
well they got 2600 of that day
right but yeah 600.
on youtube these videos for the like
uncanceled tour or whatever they call it
these videos are not beating 150 views
right well i mean it's not surprising i
mean somebody some uh dark pepsi brings
up
uh
rumble 2 since the opposite of youtube
now i'll go to rumble and let's see how
many oh also it's like how many rumbles
did you get on this let me let me let me
go look let me go look yeah yeah go go
check out go check out the um
i mean here's another example while
you're looking that up this is may 19th
um when you're talking about you know
here here they are in budapest
um talking about i'm not really exactly
sure but matt schlapp who is a verified
account uh his account says he has 348
000 followers he had six retweets on
this thing
match schlapp and cipa and cpac
retweeted this is one of them
his account is one of them now here's
what i'm trying to tell you guys
is that cpac
it's all [ __ ] phony
it's all [ __ ]
phony it's phony ass [ __ ] it's to
confuse their dumbass voters that they
got this big huge support and they don't
they can't even get social media
engagement on the largest social media
site they can't do it they can't [ __ ]
do it the eight-hour and 45-minute
stream in hungary on may 19th
462 views
on rumble god damn that's on may 20th
yeah
yeah eight eight hours 32 410 views
baby this is cpac these are very it's a
verified account right that's it right
it's all [ __ ] phony folks it's all
[ __ ] and drive the wedge drive the
wedge because if cpac and this message
from hungary was so [ __ ] popular and
that's what they wanted and that's what
they wanted to do and that's where they
wanted to go guess what there would be
millions of views on this stuff because
we see project veritas can drop a video
and they'll get millions of views
on a video they drop on twitter millions
of [ __ ] views jack will spread it
around and
but he can't even garnish up a couple
thousand views on their live feed get
the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ] i
also want to say that jack prostate is
very sensitive he once had a live stream
on twitter and he was talking about
doing some sort of
talk or speech at some conference and i
called him out for a couple things and
uh i got blocked within probably the
first oh you were in the chat i was in
the chat and i was like he was saying
stuff and i was calling out and like
throwing links in to be like oh actually
this actually that and within the first
minute
uh
blocked out done he doesn't like free
speech man well they don't that's why
they say they do it's projection
it's projection speaking of orbon and
hungary and importing exporting their
style fascism rather we're exporting
american manga style fascism there we're
importing hungarian orban style fascism
here this is david pepper we watched a
video last week of david explaining um
about how republicans have abandoned
most of america and convince them with
with religion and abortion to keep
voting for them even though they leave
them in the dust literally sometimes
uh david here this is a video i believe
from january that he reposted when when
it was when tucker carlson went and did
an interview with him and this sort of
thing he actually did a great video but
you know this stuff stays relevant
because they just are they just won't
quit but listen to how david explains
hungarian fascism and why these american
maga
fascists are so
so enamored with it the quick white
board
on trump's announcement yesterday
of endorsement for viktor orban of
hungary and he's not the first guy to do
this steve bannon loves orban tucker
carlson interviewed him last year in
hungary cpac will be in hungary this
year to talk about this this man why do
they like him so much
uh well more than other autocrats he's
perfected a system that the academics
call competitive autocracy
and what this is is a system where you
maintain power even when you're in the
minority
by rigging every aspect of grabbing
power so it's predetermined but you do
it in a way that it looks legitimate
so here's here is david pepper and he's
going to explain this to you but it
really if you listen to his language
there gabe it really does sound like the
[ __ ] that the fascist accuse other
people of
and it really is projection because
listen to how he describes there's three
parts of this there's three parts of
this authoritarianism that he that that
he describes that comes into power but
it really is projection listen it looks
sort of democratic that's what orban has
done to a t in hungary now how does he
do this one
through gerrymandering he has rigged the
parliament of hungary
so his party always stays in power even
when the voters vote the other way in
fact recently even though they got a
minority of the votes
uh orban's party had a super majority
two-thirds uh of the members of
parliament now that's a rigged election
so if you listen to him there what he's
describing in hungary is where the
majority of ideology
does not have the majority of votes in
the legislator
in the legislative style body or the
parliament as it is there here it's we
have you know we have the united states
house representatives and the senate
but it really does
start to sound like
start to sound like the what we have
here where more people are voting
for less people in representation it
really is kind of
it's almost also like they went to
hungary to get a little bit of a lesson
well you might bring that lesson
right right well you might want to take
a master class on fascism you know and
where better to go than or by any cliff
notes some hot tips you know that you
want to give us so then we go back we
know exactly what to say how to say it
and where to say it right you know right
well you know and they act like they
gathered up tens of people in a room and
slapped the hungarian flag on cpac the
unpatriotic way it was if you noticed it
was sitting room only everyone had to be
in chairs and it was also only a tight
again another tight shot where you can
see no more than probably 35 people well
you those tens of people in the room
let's finish the other two things are
important here that he brings up number
two
they continue to attack the judiciary
whoa whoa it's independence so it won't
be a check and balance and they also are
doing things such as stripping away its
jurisdiction over issues like elections
so they will wait a second that sounds
familiar too attacking the the judiciary
we have we have we have a branch in this
country i forget what it's called what
is that one branch called gabe that we
have there's the executive
the legislative what's the other one
there's the legislative judicial
judiciary oh that's what it is yeah
because there's the checks and balances
you know
you can't just let one
one side do it all you have to you know
make your make your make your decisions
and your your your choices and then the
other side has to say oh actually we're
going to counteract that we need to make
sure you don't have too much power or
too much control right
so this seems kind of funny because he's
talking about in the first one he says
that you have to rig the legislator by
you know gerrymandering in some other
ways to make sure that the minority
ideology has the majority of votes in
those legislators right and then he's
saying you have to really bang up the
judiciary this sounds familiar to the
stuff that they say on trader tv all the
time right all the time let's listen to
what the third one is here i wonder what
it could be won't be an independent
check and balance on matters around
elections and other critical issues
third
they are attacking the elections process
itself so they have more control over it
and these elections are not run
independently uh they also rather than
non-stop attacks the media and that rig
parliament is also allowing him to
pursue very far right-wing social uh
attacks on for example lgbtq hungarians
and there's nothing anyone can do about
it
this all sounds familiar
and almost it almost sounds like what
you said they went over took a master
class yeah they're like look just write
down what you're doing here we will go
try to do it there yeah and here's the
thing folks that they're that orban is
using democracy in his country to tear
down democracy like he's using it as the
machine to undo itself right which
there's a lot of loopholes because
democracy is messy democracy is hard
democracy is a long road like it's not
the short road autocracy is actually the
thing that is the short road to
quote-unquote solutions to problems
that's why fascists love autocracy they
love it because you wave a magic wand
and you can get rid of i don't know say
a whole group of people like lgbtq like
crazy you know a whole group of people
you just get rid of them you know you
just wave a magic wand you know there's
no constitution standing in a way no no
parliament no legislator nope no
judiciary standing in your way no
elections standing in your way once you
rig it up because here's what they're
doing they're not only trying to change
election laws these fascists are trying
to get secretaries of states and
attorney generals that won't stand in
the way of republicans taking away your
vote they won't stand in the way of them
yeah because they don't want those
checks and balances it's
oh he's you know
well he's going to say checks and
balances in our democracy and under our
constitution
the is the advancement
of equality and equity and that's what
they don't want ultimately yeah no i was
going to say was it's almost like um
you know for these people who say
they're constitutionalists and they want
to follow the found founding fathers
how quickly they are willing to
uh uphold the constitution by tearing it
down right to right by ripping it up and
taking away the thing that our founding
fathers they said well one body can't
have so much power we don't have uh we
we want to have a democracy we want to
make sure that there is a checks and
balances process in place between these
three branches so that we always make
sure that we're doing what's best for
you know the the citizens in this
country and then we pass the laws and
govern how we should
but those same people that are like oh
you know it you know you're not going to
take away our first amendment or second
amendment right and dot it out of this
and this and that
they're also the same party that's
willing to rip up the constitution and
say no no
we want to make sure that we win
when we win
however we win
because we say we won not because we
actually let democracy say and dictate
who actual the winner is
we want to determine beforehand i would
say this person running is actually
going to win we don't really care what
you have to say because democracy is
actually a piece of [ __ ] that's that's
what i'm hearing i bet they would even
go to the capitol building during
official proceeding to try to stop
just try to stop our vote from counting
i bet they would even do that and
probably even smear that [ __ ] that
you're talking about all over the
[ __ ] wall yeah no took a [ __ ] smeared
it and then clean our hands with the
constitution that is exactly what i feel
like they did let's finish what david
has to say here and then we're gonna
have to we're running out of time
so this is how they're maintaining power
in this system of a competitive
autocracy
but they do it a way that looks
legitimate and that's why trump and the
others love it so much but this isn't
just a crystal ball about what might
happen if trump were to get into power
again which scarce is scary enough this
is also a mirror into what's happening
in america today because everything i
just
described actually exists in state
houses across america right now by
legitimizing orban what they're doing is
legitimizing the broken democracy in
state after state and that is important
what he's saying there at the end folks
is that he's saying go vote in your
state it's the congressional races the
the united states senate races those are
very very very important and we have to
show up we have to use our ballot to
make sure that we beat back this orban
style fascism
but it also happens inside your local
races the governors the legislators the
the town councils the county commissions
it's all there we have to the school
boards as we've seen earlier this is all
important to beat back this orban style
fascism this authoritarianism that are
trying to take over our democracy in our
state and use it against us to take it
away from us so be pro-democracy show
your pro-democracy and never never stop
fighting with your ballot and with your
vote and with your voice and we will not
stop with our voice here every single
weekday monday through friday noon
eastern 11 central nine pacific on
youtube twitter twitch do not forget to
subscribe to the youtube channel you're
going to want to subscribe also we
simulcast from the midas test facebook
page
gabe until tomorrow i had fun surfing
the day it was fun
today which is crazy we're gonna have to
end it today we're gonna end it today
but tomorrow
we will surf some more so until then
surf's up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
inger face commentary of current events
in political news no rules no boundaries
i think we've made that perfectly clear
we hope you enjoyed the show and we'll
be back soon in the meantime follow tony
on social media at the tony michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking